اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح اهلا بكم كتائب
القسام تعلن تدمير خمس دبابات وناقلي جند
في محيط مخيم البريج واستهداف حشود
الاحتلال بقذائف الهاون بمحاور التوغل كما
نشرت صورا لطائره استطلاع اسرائيليه
استولت عليها اثناء تحليقها بمهمه
استخباراتيه غربي بيت حنو وسرايا القدس
تقول انها استهدفت ناقله جند دبابتين في
مدينه غزه في حين اسفر القصف الاسرائيلي
على مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه عن عشرات
الشهداء
والجرحى جنوب افريقيا تتقدم بدعوه ضد
اسرائيل في محكمه العدل الدوليه لانتهاكها
اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه وارتكابها
افعالا تهدف للتطهير العرقي في مدينه غزه
من جهتها اتهمت تلابيب جنوب افريقيا
بالتعاون مع جماعه ارهابيه تدعو الى تدمير
اسرائيل في حين قالت المقرره الامميه
لحقوق الانسان بالاراضي الفلسطينيه
للجزيره ان نيه اسرائيل واضحه لتدمير
الشعب
الفلسطيني وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تنقل عن
مصادر عسكريه ان الجيش منزعج من ان
القياده السياسيه لم تحدد بعد اهداف
استمرار الحرب ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تقول ان نتنياهو منع رئيسي الشباك
والموساد من حضور مناقشه امنيه حساسه مع
وزير
في حين اكد القيادي في حركه حماس اسامه
حمدان للجزيره ان حديث عن صفقه تبادل قبل
وقف
العدوه وسط تصعيد متواصل في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تداهم مخيم الجلزون وتعتقل
14 فلسطينيا وبعد ساعات من اصابه خمسه
جنود اسرائيليين في عمليه دهس قرب الخليل
احدهم بحاله خطره الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
قتل المنفذ في حين كشفت هي البث
الاسرائيليه ان الاجهزه الفلسطينيه تتحرك
في مخيمه الضفه لمنع هجمات مسلحه ضد الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى
اللقاء